are you looking for a job in cyber
security the good news is there's plenty
of rules out
[Music]
there here in the United States there
are over 600,000 open cyber security
jobs just waiting to be filled and
that's on top of the 1.1 million people
who are already working in the field
that means cyber Security Professionals
are in such short supply there is a
negative employment rate of over 50% if
you want to get started as an
entry-level cybercity analyst there are
130,000 jobs openings for that role
alone the average wage is a six fig
salary of $112,000 a year and with
20,000 breaches over the last 17 years
and more than 2 billion consumer records
impacted and counting it doesn't look
like hiring will be stopping anytime
soon so if you're interested in becoming
part of this growing field join us and
learn how at Stanford
online